Ads tell us milk, does a body good.
But are we talking whole milk or 2%?
It’s not what you think.
Hi guys, Lissette here for DNews.
If you were a child of the eighties or nineties
your parents likely poured you some low fat
milk - it was all the rave.
In fact in 1985, the United States Department
of Agriculture officially recommended a switch
to skim milk - three glasses of it a day.
But, more recently, we’ve begun collecting
evidence that says the USDA might be missing
an important piece of the story.
In a recent study published in the journal
Circulation, researchers looked at data that
spanned about 15 years.
They were specifically interested in how dairy
fat biomarkers in the blood are related to
diabetes.
What they found might surprise the USDA.
Higher concentrations of dairy fat biomarkers
were associated with lowered risk of diabetes.
And whole milk has been tied to more than
just a decrease in diabetes.
Another study published in the Journal of
American Nutrition looked at its relation
to obesity in more than 18,000 women over
the course of about 11 years.
They found that high dairy fat intake was
associated with less weight gain and lowered
risk of obesity.
In fact, a meta-review of 25 different studies
published in the European Journal of Nutrition,
supports these findings.
Researchers found that there are no benefits
linked to low fat dairy compared to whole
fat.
When it comes to type 2 diabetes and cardiovascular
disease, people who consume either products
come out about the same.
What’s more, their data indeed indicated
that full-fat dairy is associated with lower
obesity rates.
Eighteen of the 25 studies showed that participants
were either at lower risk for obesity, experienced
less weight gain, or weighed less overall
than those who consumed low fat dairy.
The results for the other seven were inconclusive;
but, altogether these studies suggest that
at the very least, full fat milk is on par
with skim milk.
But, this isn’t really a story about milk.
We’re not suggesting you go chug down a
glass - in fact, if you’re like two thirds
of the population, the lactose in it will
cause some nasty side-effects.
And it’s not really a story about fat, either.
Rather, it’s more about what we do when
we cut the fat.
See, what some scientists think ends up happening
when we drink low fat milk, is that our bodies
try to make up for the lost calories.
Simply put we stay hungrier than if we were
to drink whole milk.
And rather than reaching for, say a zucchini
or cooking up a chicken breast, we tend to
load up on carbs.
Our body then turns excess carbohydrates into
sugar, which then gets stored in our bodies
as fat - yes, those fluffy love handles.
It’s sort of ironic that cutting fat in
our diets leads to more fat on our bodies
- but this is exactly what’s happening.
In short, all these associations between milk
fat and its benefits may be due to our behavior
- not what milk fat does to our bodies specifically.
So before you go inhale a glass of whole milk
hoping to be healthier, you might instead
want to pay attention to the variety of foods
you’re eating and drinking.